And I would say that all of these are concerns that you should have when you're
thinking about the metric that you should pick.
And they do all happen to be problems with accuracy in the,
in the case of identifying persons of interest.
So, accuracy can give you a problem when you have skewed
classes because the denominator of this formula, all the items in this class,
ends up being a very small number, which means the accuracy that you compute as
a result is something that you might not be sort of as, as trustworthy of as if
you have lots and lots of examples of, of instances of that class.
Also, the second two options are going to be things you want to think about,
that you want to pick an, a metric that's really tailored to the operation
that you're trying to do, and that, as a result, you might want to maximize
the chance that you err on the side of guessing that someone's innocent.
Or that conversely,
you err on the side of flagging them as a person of interest even if it
means that you catch more innocent people sort of in your net as a result.
Accuracy is not particularly well-suited to either of these outcomes, but
there are some evaluation metrics that are, and
that will be what we talk about in this lesson.